hey what's up guys by popular request we
are recreating
steamed hams from the simpsons but this
is not binging with babish it is
the burger show
when babish and i get together it's
always an epic adventure
and this time is no exception today
we're exploring one of the most iconic
burgers from cartoon history
steamed hams from the simpsons baby's
gonna steam his first burger
and i'm gonna make my own version to see
if i can take it to the next level
internet this one's for you
darn this zoom thing i'd never know how
to use these darn things
hello what's up dude hello can you help
me hello coming in loud and clear on the
main vlog
today we're in the babish world of
recreating foods from pop culture
and we're going to recreate some steamed
hams this is one of the longest running
requests
on my show uh to re to recreate these
steamed hams from a storied dinner
at uh principal skinner's house on the
simpsons shout out to this steam tam
army
steam him army thank you for fighting
the good fight
fighting i don't know we're steaming
hamburgers we're steaming hamburgers
like a couple of true sociopaths have
you had a steamed hamburger i've never
had a steamed hamburger i i have
reservations about it
steaming a burger makes no sense to me i
watched george moats make them on your
show i'm going to make them the way that
he made them
uh roughly in like a home cook
approximation and we're also going to
try to be true
to the way that the burgers looked on
the simpsons the steamed hams
which were really just crusty burgers
which we don't really know what go in
crusty burgers so
we're we're we're mixing it up today
we're not we're stretching a little bit
we're gonna make it happen so principal
skinner was obviously just
lying to cover his ass um but
we are deciding to take his words very
literally today
because in recreating this burger the
only option we really have is to make a
steamed hamburger and the only steamed
hamburger
that anyone seems to know of is at a
place called ted's
in connecticut yeah there's a there's a
few steamed hamburger joints
in a nine by nine mile radius but ted's
is the one of no
it's world famous now because of their
steamed hamburgers they have their own
like custom-made contraptions
that steams the cheese steams the meat
and honestly
as someone who's been there it's
definitely got a
huge local following we actually tracked
down
the writer of the steam damned episode
let's hear what he has to say about
the steamed hams take it away oakley hi
burger show fans my name is bill oakley
and i wrote the much
meme steamed hams segment from the
simpsons episode 22 short films about
springfield at the time i didn't know
that there was a regional burger
called the steamed cheeseburger in fact
i just heard of that a couple years ago
and it is baffling to me that such a
thing exists and has existed for a long
time i guess
a couple years ago i started to do uh
instagram videos
of fast food reviews kind of
transitioned from a simpsons writer into
a amateur
fast food critic i've never had a
steamed cheeseburger although i've had a
lot of people send me
photos and videos of the steamed
cheeseburger okay babish and alvin you
have your work cut out for you
but i can't wait to see what you come up
with he's never had it you've never had
it
it's open what's up again let's make one
and uh
maybe this will be a great guide for him
so he can make it on his own so he
doesn't have to go all the way to
wherever connecticut and since i'm the
only one that's ever tried it you should
have to trust my word
and you're not even trying mine so yeah
your eyes
yeah just trust your eyeballs and uh
let's see what happens
yeah steamed ham
steamed ham so
i want to try to stay true to the
steamed
cheeseburger from ted's and from that
region of connecticut
but i also wanted to visually match what
we see in the simpsons so we got
some red stuff on the bottom of the
burger i assume that's ketchup then we
got the burger itself
then we got pickles and then we got some
orange stuff now
at ted's they use white cheddar i'm just
going to use uh yellow cheddar to match
that orange because it's
you know they say yellow cheddar but
this is orange cheddar that is a zombie
as it comes so ted's uses their custom
steam
cabinet and i don't have one of those
handy unlike most americans i don't have
one
around instead i'm going to use a bamboo
steamer basket that's the best option
for me
and i've got the cheese in these little
ramekins here so i got some water at the
boil here
i'm going to throw down this layer and
then i'm gonna throw down my
burger patty guys i understand it's just
ground chuck
at ten right so i just got some real
standard ground beef here i didn't grind
it myself nothing fancy
for the uh oh
problem let's uh switch to a different
kind of ramekin
yes no ramekin size affects millions of
men every year
and it's nothing to be ashamed of
gentlemen anyway uh
all right so i got like i got the cheese
in uh
some slightly smaller ramekins here
don't be embarrassed
and then i'm just gonna place those in
i'm gonna
get this guy to a rolling simmer and i'm
gonna let these steam
for like uh seven minutes until the
burger's fully cooked and the cheese is
fully melted and then we're gonna dump
it all out under the roll sound good
sounds good we're all right we're on our
roll we're out
seven minutes we're not on our roll yet
but we'll be on a roll alvin right after
these messages
my burgers are done steaming is a
sentence that i never thought i'd say
i just love that setup man it just makes
so much sense so first thing going down
is some ketchup there's very clearly
some red stuff on the bottom of the
burger
with some ketchup these burgers shrunk
significantly
and i'm gonna apply my pickles with a
gigantic set of tweezers
yeah you have to few mozart playing in
the background
captain beefheart now i have my molten
cheese here which
here we go it's nice and hot i'm going
to go ahead
and dump it out that's super burger show
accurate right there
yeah that's pornographic there we go and
that
ladies and gentlemen is a steamed ham
there oh it's a little pink
no it's not just there's the ketchup i
thought it was i got excited
i thought it was pink it's nice and gray
yeah there you go all right i'm gonna
eat this before it burns me
okay
what do you think steam hams steamed ham
that's a verdict
that's not great that's not great
i mean i don't think it's the fault of
the steamed ham i think there's too much
ketchup on this
it's not bad but you know what it
reminds me of is the burgers that they
used to serve me in high school
that those were those were cooked on a
steam table so it
makes sense it's just not what i
look for in a burger i i need the crust
uh we're reading way too far into this
joke and
the better way to honor uh the steamed
ham
as a concept is to make a legitimately
delicious steamed ham alvin how you
gonna do that for us
as much as i'm like a burger purist and
i like
pay homage to the classics i kind of
wanted to take my own spin on this and
bump it up a little bit
and uh what i have in here is
beef stock i mean just the smell in here
smells like i got like this big
pot of beef flavored top ramen going on
all that is going to permeate into what
i think is already a really
beefy patty so this is custom ground at
my new spot
it has chuck short rib it has
brisket and then you see these flakes of
fat that's from a dry aged
rib cap from a prime rib that has got to
be the most beautiful burger i've ever
seen or heard of in my life
we got some onions that i'm going to
throw in the steamer it has a little bit
of butter in it good old processed
provolone cheese paying homage to
another connecticut classic
um square bread uh louie's lunch
and then i got some spicy pickle relish
and uh
some sour cream and onion chips for
crunch
this is this is genius so let's let's
start off with opening up the steamer
i'm gonna throw the patty in onions with
the butter
and the cheese yeah we want to cook the
seasoning
into the into the burger all right
so let's toss this guy in the secret
sauce is not much of a secret and you
know what at ted's
they put mustard mayo
ketchup separately so why not just
combine it yeah
hot italian pickles i'm pretty excited
now i'm excited i can smell the food
you know that's not [ __ ] now now i'm
taking it beyond the simpsons now it's
turned into like my special project
i'm starting to feel it starting to feel
good about it ooh
you think this is something that might
end up in your restaurant
probably not
i really respect the honesty oh
shoot check this out what happened with
that cheese
that cheese is done though bro get that
we got some of this
buttered onions buttered onion every
word that out of your mouth
just gets me going all right oh wow
throw that on there sour cream and
onion i want a cross section
not that good oh that crunch i heard it
from here oh yeah
let's do this see it okay
i'm getting patty melt vibes right now
oh big time
how we feeling this is not bad
i wasn't sure where you're going with
that i saw the pause you were like
textures are great
and because of the dry age i'm getting
really big
beef flavor honestly
it's a pretty damn good burger chips on
a sandwich is such a move
i can't ever say that i've heard of
chips on a burger
and i would not be surprised if you
sparked the revolution today i just
created a nationwide concept
steamed patty melts steamed patty milk
chip
burgers and i not to sound cocky and to
suit my own horn but i [ __ ] nailed it
hey beep beep toot it all right
read a book uh or re-watch sopranos
or make the steamed ham what hobby are
you gonna take up this weekend
make a steamed ham disclaimer you're
gonna have to dry clean your [ __ ]
because i smell like beet broth right
now
burger show be there there you have it
folks
burger show
what's up everybody thank you for
watching the burger show make sure you
hit that like button
make sure you smash that subscribe
button hit that notification bell
if not for me for the burgers thank you